[Music]
some of you may already know this but
I'm very happy to announce that we are
taking our show on the road to the great
city of Chicago June 11th through the
14th yeah we'll be taping four nights at
the historic Chicago Theatre as part of
the TBS Just for Laughs Chicago Comedy
Festival to get tickets you go to team
koco.com slash Chicago okay and the best
I like people that get that little over
there is the best part is as always
tickets are absolutely free whoa whoa
whoa nothing in life is free what's the
catch no sir there is no catch tickets
are free Yeah right who do I have to
sleep with for your Chicago tickets now
you don't you don't have to sleep with
anyone I said they're free yeah that's
what they always say you sign up for
free tickets then you find out you've
agreed to buy a timeshare in Boca Raton
okay no there's no hidden motives
tickets are free my ass one day you sign
up for some free tickets and think
you're going to see Wheel of Fortune
next thing you know you'll wake up on a
slab and your kidney is missing
I want my kidney back Pat Sajak o comedy
eyes pretty boy and this time I'm
believing with three kidneys
[Applause]
after the show I think we should call
Patsy let's wait a while alright once
again for free tickets go to team
koco.com slash Chicago we will see you
in Chicago that's good